high point man for the bucks with 17  holidays at eight of 12 from the field  here's schroeder gets it back out  trying to set up the sole nice pass from  the gasol  lebron  [Music]  [Applause]  saying that's clean don't wait till  lebron reacts to call the foul anthony  cooper saying  you know my resume one of the best shot  blockers in the game let's see  oh that's clean  or that angle it looks clean i should  say  lebron continuing the conversation  as he felt he was hit in the mouth  the ball carried out about so it goes  back to the box  [Applause]  but apparently it's a foul  lebron is still upset by that previous  play  [Music]  and now offensive goaltending may have  been to call let's see  i wonder how that could be unless he  tried to go back and  put that same dunk in while holding onto  the rim  no oh  called for grabbing the rim that's  basket interference